what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we officially are going to begin
it's really more of a prelude than
anything else but this gets us into the
territory of the iron male which is a
guy by the name of ranch in I think it
is he was a guy created by Rick Remender
but it's basically the villainous
responsible for stripping Captain
America of his Super Soldier Serum and
it's really cool because he's basically
the reason Steve Rogers becomes an old
man and it's really really interesting
it kind of set the stage for only
all-different marvel different things
like that but for those the guys who
read Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and do
Avengers infinity that kind of stuff
this is the reason why that happened now
something else that I want to point out
here and this is something that I
haven't really brought up up to this
point if you were to go through and you
were to look up like Avengers and New
Avengers you were to look up like the
pre loot to Secret Wars you wanted to
look up the events that led into the
collapse of the multiverse and so on and
so forth you would read through Avengers
and new Avengers and then suddenly you
would pick up a story called eight
months later what eight months later was
designed to do was basically follow up
all these individual stories because
remember Marvel still had a ton of
stories going on for individual
characters and teams when the events of
Secret Wars suddenly kicked off you
basically had last days and so on and so
forth and so what that meant is between
betrayed eight months later and the
story before it all this stuff with
Captain America took place all the
things with Black Widow and with the
Incredible Hulk and all that kind of
stuff all that took place and so it'll
be kind of interesting because what
we'll actually do is when we get to our
marble cosmology we'll roll Captain
America into you know that playlist and
will actually stick it right between
these two things eight months later and
the story that came before it you guys
will be able to see it in chronological
order but I just kind of wanted to throw
that out but again Rick Remender is
amazing when it comes to how it is that
he writes Steve Rogers and what's so
funny about this is you can see the Rick
Romero I guess yeah you can really see
the inspiration from Rick Remender
and the writing of Nick Spencer put
regards to all-new all-different Captain
America and you know with regards to
secret Empire and all that kind of good
stuff because what we end up having here
is basically Steve Rogers after the
events of dimension Z when he had
basically spent 12 years and side of
this other dimension or time pass faster
only to find out that once he got back
in the main Marvel Universe only thirty
minutes had passed and so he experienced
twelve years of living he experienced
what it was like to basically take a
child who was being raised by a disco
and then make that child a super
hero more or less teach that child teach
in everything he knew about what it
meant to stand up to do the right thing
but all of these lessons that Steve
Rogers passed on to his adopted son came
by way of the lessons that were passed
on to him from his mother and that's the
coolest thing is because what Rick
Remender gives us are these really
touching final moments and it's really
cool because as she tells him these
lessons actually teaches him these
things we also get this sort of over run
where he's basically going through
surgery to get rid of the last little
tidbits of Arnim Zola that are stuck
inside of his body of course a lot of
this work is being done by Bruce Banner
and Hank Pym it's so cool to see this
because his mother says Steve Rodgers
has been through so much and he has I
mean as a child he lived through the
Great Depression he saw what it was to
live in abject poverty he experienced a
father who have used his mother you know
and right now he's basically seeing his
mother dying and so because of that she
basically says look the road that you've
taken the path to that that life has put
you on has the ability to send you in
two different directions you are coming
up on a fork in the road when the time
comes that I leave this world you will
be at a fork and you can go left and
become a horrible human being the world
is terrible the world's bad just become
this really cynical person that's just
filled with anger and negativity or you
can go right and become every bit of the
man that I know you are you can become
optimistic and she passes these things
on to him she says people are optimistic
people try to do the right thing if
given the choice between right and wrong
people will do right but the funny thing
about this is we can also kind of
attribute this to like an archaic method
of thinking right a cynical person would
say no no that's how things used to be
but people don't don't think like that
anymore and they don't talk like that
anymore but then again that's just a
reflection of what it is that we happen
to see or what we choose to see with
regards to what it is it is mother
saying here in their heart of hearts
when it comes down to it when you strip
past all the layers when you get past
all the struggle and strife people are
inherently good and she says no matter
what happens no matter what happens to
you no matter what what roads what
events that you see after this you
always have to do the right thing you
always have to be the right guy you have
to make the decisions that you think are
best you have to fight on behalf of what
you think is right but these are very
general terms these are very general
ideas do the right thing
fight for the right cause
stand up for those who cannot stand up
for themselves but this is all just a
reflection of Captain America as we
traditionally see him and you know to
kind of bring in secret Empire for a
second because this is really all kind
of leading up to that so I think we can
have this bit of a discussion bringing
in secret Empire for a second that's
what makes this so cool and that's what
makes secret Empire so cool is because
we think of Captain America and he does
the right thing he always fights the
good fight he stands up for people they
can't help themselves
all the while championing the American
flag what if he did all those things but
instead of an American flag he had a
Hydra flag well then suddenly it changes
everything because now he's not fighting
for American ideals he's fighting for
Hydra ideals and Hydra ideals are
different from American ideals but it's
also a reflection of society and that's
really what Nick Spencer is doing with
secret Empire he's basically criticizing
modern society he's criticizing how
things function at the moment but in the
realm of Marvel Comics secret Empire was
just the most logical outcome of the
events that have transpired so far I
mean with Captain America being a Hydra
agent and looking around and just kind
of biding his time waiting for a chance
to take over the world he wakes up one
morning only to find out that Thanos had
decided to invade the planet Earth why
because of the fact that he's trying to
wipe out all of his offspring across the
universe and one of them just happens to
be on earth this leads to a war with the
Inhumans blackbolt absolutely freaks out
in a state of panic detonates the
Terrigen bomb which begins spreading the
myths all across the planet earth these
myths just happened to be deadly to
mutants and when the mutants ask the
Inhumans to stop the Inhumans say no
because our numbers are growing it would
be like us asking you to stop having
mutants that are born to simply
eliminate mutants in their entirety this
leads to a war between the Inhumans and
the mutants but during this time and
inhuman is suddenly born that has the
ability to supposedly see into the
future Carol Danvers takes it as an
absolute truth this leads to a conflict
between her and Tony Stark setting off
the second civil war all the while
Captain America is just watching the
events unfold and watching this
superhero community become more and more
fractured the Avengers are going in
there fighting various villains there's
collateral damage people are completely
displaced when their homes are destroyed
and the Avengers just leave allowing
damage control Incorporated to take over
Kamala Khan and Miles Morales and a
handful of others get tired of seeing
that so they branch off when the
Avengers they form their own faction
called the champions
Captain America looks around and sees
the superhero community society itself
is more and
or fracture Sam Wilson is the new
Captain America and people don't like it
because it's different from what they're
used to and as a result humanity within
the realm of the Marvel Universe
starts tweeting out things like hashtag
not my captain if society itself became
as fractured as it did over something as
nonsensical as who it is is wearing
Captain America shield
if superheroes can't get along if
they're waging war against one another
if Captain America sits down and says
society is inherently broken and I is
Captain America I'm a protector of
society then the only option I have here
is to protect society from itself
and that ultimately leads to him
stepping in initiating all these
different plans becoming director of
shield and dominating the entirety of
the United States setting his sights on
the rest of the world it's an amazing
series of events that all led up to the
singular instance of Captain America
ruling everything now of course again
this all really predates that kind of
getting back into this story a little
bit because they kind of got off it got
up on a bit of a tangent this predates
all that this is still the Captain
America that you guys know and love when
you think of Steve Rogers but the cool
thing here is that this all really just
kind of leads to that final moment it
leads to that grandiose scenario of
Captain America being point being
appointed as director of shield and
gaining absolute power over the US
military taking control of the United
States during the events of secret
Empire number zero now what we're going
to do here is we're actually going to
jump back a little bit to 1968 and the
reason why is because we're actually
going to join a guy by the name of Rand
Shen now Ram chin is effectively a guy
who was formerly a SHIELD agent that's
kind of the crazy thing here is because
of the fact that we end up seeing him
just sort of approaching this dragon
that looks an awful lot like Fin Fang
Foom but the result here is that a
bargain is more or less struck now we're
not given a whole lot of information
about this dragon all we're really told
here is that this thing basically has
the ability to imbue Shin with some
measure of power we don't know what that
means we don't really know what it makes
incapable of it at least not right off
the bat what we do instead is we
actually end up jumping forward a little
bit to 1969 by about a year and we
basically have Shen being held captive
by dum-dum Dugan and Nick Fury now this
is when we learned most of the backstory
about his character that he was
basically one of the absolute best
shield agents that were out there but he
was assigned the task of infiltrating
Communist China during its rise to power
and see
it was basically a way that Apple
Chairman Mao but what this ended up
doing is a basically led to Shen
becoming corrupted by the power that he
possessed as he rose through the ranks
eventually being ousted by Chairman Mao
himself which led to shin encountering
mr. Agra in the first place
and so what just does is it basically
shows us this is how Nick Fury and this
is how dum-dum Dugan lose their infinity
serum now it's just something that's
interesting because not a lot of people
know about this the infinity serum is
what it is that allowed Nick theory to
stay so young for such a length of time
this would force all really kind of goes
back into the idea of Nick Fury and his
Howling Commandos back in the 1960s when
Marlowe first introduced Nick Fury in
his Howling Commandos they were
basically just a world war two team but
the cool thing is that their history
delved into a lot of different things
for example they were tasked with
finding dr. Abraham Erskine and bringing
him to the United States Abraham Erskine
of course being the man who was
responsible for making Steve Rodgers
into Captain America so again Nick
Fury's Howling Commandos had a lot of
hands at a lot of different events that
had taken place over the course of
Marvel Comics but along the way they had
discovered an infinity formula that if
ingested would basically slow the aging
process and I don't know exactly what
the ratio is but for the sake of this
discussion we'll say you know 10 or I
guess one for every 10 so for every
every 10 years the past they only ever
paged by like one year that's just kind
of throwing a random number out there I
don't think we're ever ever actually
given an exact number but it gives you
an idea of how slow they aged but the
fact remains that in the middle of this
interrogation process a ranch in
basically attacks Nick Fury and dum-dum
Dugan and strips them of their infinity
formula now this is basically
recommenders setting up the events of
the conflict between Ranchin and Captain
America himself where ranch initially
going by the name the iron nail and ends
up stripping Steve Rogers of the Super
Soldier Serum but again it's a really
really cool bit of storytelling here the
reason why is because of the fact that
after Reed awning one of his shield
outfits shin is basically tracked down
by Bucky Barnes now Bucky Barnes had
been assigned to basically kill shin
just by virtue of his role as part of
the Winter Soldier under the control of
the Russians and it was a different set
of events that was taking place in
bitter March but the idea here is that
this also coincides with a point in time
when Nick Fury did not know who Bucky
Barnes is and so again for those of you
guys who read Edgar Bay
run that saw the return of Bucky Barnes
to Marvel Comics when Nick Fury was the
one who is giving steve rogers all this
information on the Winter Soldier the
idea that it might be Bucky Barnes this
series of events right here is what set
the stage but Nick Fury to launch that
investigation in the first place
eventually leading up to Ed Brubaker run
and the revelation that Bucky Barnes was
still alive at least as far as Captain
America knew so again a lot of history
is being made in this little bit of a
story a monitor a lot of information is
kind of being thrown at us as it was
really kind of cool to see how all the
dots connect and how it all really just
kind of comes together but one of the
last little tidbits that we end up
picking up here is the concept of weapon
- now we have a video that I've already
made on a history of Weapon X of weapons
plus all that kind of stuff so you guys
can basically check that video out
you'll find it down in the description
but weapon - was basically shields
response to weapons Plus for the program
to basically set the stage for the
introduction of will rain Wade Wilson
becoming Deadpool weapons Plus was
basically the one to set all that stuff
up you know phantom X and all that kind
of good stuff but the fact remains that
behind this door is actually a guy by
the name of dr. mind bubble and we'll
learn a little bit more about him later
on in terms of the role that he plays
here but at this point we actually kind
of jumped back to the modern day and
what we end up finding out is between
the time that that Shin escapes and
adopted the mantle of iron nail up into
the modern day he's essentially
operating out of the Great Wall of China
and what he's doing is he's going
through to all the wealthiest people
around China and basically taking them
prisoner and forcing them to work in
camps for the purpose of allowing him to
find mines or go through all the mines
all I kind of stuff whatever resources
happen to be there in addition to his
own plans but in truth this is Rick
Remender actually showing us a pretty
interesting situation on the surface we
would look at iron nail and say he's a
bad guy he's doing bad things
is he really because those individuals
who basically made their money by using
the working class for their own ends and
then disposing of them when they were of
no more use he's actually not the worst
person ever at least some individuals
would say that not only that it's also
Rick Remender kind of poking fun at this
idea of money and how very you know how
worthless it is for example these guys
that are being brought here are
billionaires they're people with so much
money but for all the money that they
have what good does it do them they're
still working in these case just like
everybody else they're being made to
work to the point that they die just
like everybody else where's their
billions of dollars where's their cars
where's their houses how is any of that
going to protect them when it all came
down to it who they were as people was
the only thing they had and that wasn't
enough to do them any help and so again
it's really kind of this idea that these
extremely wealthy individuals kind of
surrounded themselves with all the
resources in the world only to find out
to those resources meant absolutely
nothing now this is when we get into the
idea I guess really a little bit of a
follow up with regards to Captain
America and the reason why is because of
the fact to remember following his
escape from Dimension Z he was also
joined with jet-black basically the
daughter of Arnim Zola who had been
specifically engineered for the purpose
of being somebody able to engage in
combat but what we also find out is that
a deal was struck between Steve Rogers
and jet black the jet black was
inevitably going to be brought in by a
shield now of course she's currently
being interrogated by Nick Fury jr. and
to side track for second there was an
interview that Tom Brevoort did you know
one of the I think the vice-president of
something over a Marvel there was an
interview that he did with with I want
to say it was news Obama or something
like that and they were talking about
the character of Nick Fury jr. basically
the black son of Nick Fury senior who's
a white guy and when the question was
asked how do you reconcile those two
things and why is that version of Nick
Fury here the answer was what we just
need more african-american
representation and comic books which
didn't really make a whole lot of sense
because you basically had Samuel Jackson
Nick Fury in the Ultimate Universe now
the logic could be drawn here that the
Ultimate Universe was far less popular
than the main Marvel Universe in which
case the question has to be asked why
not just bring that version of Nick Fury
over but the fact remains here that's
really the only reason why his
characters here is because of the fact
that there needed to be more
african-american representation and
Marvel according to the Marvel brass
themselves so again he doesn't really
have any intrinsic value here he's
really just here for the sake of
diversity which is really kind of
interesting but the fact remains here
that with Steve Rogers showing up and
basically removing jet black from the
equation this is when we learned that
the bargain that was struck between the
two of them was the idea that jet black
would not reveal any of the information
about Ian and Steve Rogers would
basically help her cope with how to get
past or how to live in a normal life in
the main Marvel Universe and so what we
end up finding out here is that Steve
Rogers feels very out of time he feel
feels very displaced following the time
he spent in dimension Z raising Ian only
to basically realize that
was killed accidentally by Sharon Carter
and Sharon Carter herself presumably
died in the events of dimensions II and
so because of that Steve Rogers
basically feels like there's nothing
here for him now this is really kind of
Rick Remender going back and co-opting a
lot of the stuff that we saw when
Captain America first showed up in the
1960s it really first came back and
Avengers number four and the reason why
is because of the fact that back in the
1950s when Captain America was first
brought back by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
the stories of the time were designed to
be upbeat you would really never see
anything like what we're seeing now back
in their method of storytelling Stan Lee
through various interviews always stated
that they like to keep things upbeat he
like to keep things happy relatively
cheerful you know he didn't want comics
to be somewhat of a downer or in a lot
of ways a reflection of real life the
only real measure of reflection that
came and Stan Lee's early writings was
how people interacted with one another
and how teenagers were depicted and
different things like that but with this
particular bit of storytelling
Ruper mandir is very much taking the
opposite approach that you know Steve
Rogers feels very much like you did when
he was thought out during the events of
Avengers number four when he was saved
by the Avengers themselves but with
Sharon Carter being gone with his son
basically being gone there's no reason
for him to be here he feels like there's
no purpose for him in this world and so
it was really kind of cool to see a man
that's just struggling and we never
really see Captain America this way
Captain America is always the confident
guy he's always the guy on the front
lines first in last out you know because
of that is always one of the most
interesting scenarios to see him when
he's so confident when he's so strong
and then suddenly so emotional
effectively having a breakdown in front
of Sam Wilson and so again what this
does is it basically coincides with the
character of nuke now Frank Simpson was
one of the byproducts of the weapon Plus
event campaign that basically led to
James Howlett becoming war brain and
Wade Wilson becoming Deadpool but the
difference here is that Frank Simpson
basically ingest spills did amp him up
they get him prepped and excited for war
the idea here though is that somebody is
basically issuing him orders somebody is
basically telling him you need to go
into these various territories that the
United States has had wars in and
finished those guys off and because
Frank Simpson is so gung-ho because he's
so extreme this is exactly what he's
doing he's going around to different
territories where the US had conflicts
and essentially had to pull out because
they more or less
he's going through and just killing
everybody that he sees spraying them all
down with bullets and then planting
American flags and French Simpsons mind
as insane as he is he's basically
winning the war than America lost in
that particular area now the reason why
this is so significant is because of the
fact that the press has not gotten wind
of what it is it's going on but if the
media finds out that a guy with an
American flag tattoo on his face is
running amuck in countries where the
United States had previously lost
conflicts killing everybody there and
then planting American flags is going to
create an international incident and so
because of that she'll basically sends
in Steve Rogers and Sam Wilson highly
under the radar and has them take out
Frank Simpson now this is kind of
interesting because the character of
nuke in a lot of ways he looks up to
Captain America and he's not the only
one we know the Punisher for example
enlisted in the Vietnam War
because he wanted to be Captain America
and this is really Rick Remender kind of
pointing at the legacy that was made by
Steve Rogers because he was such an
iconic character because in the eyes of
a lot of people he was America
personified fighting against the Axis
powers the legacy that he created stands
the test of time as one of the most
significant legacies in the history of
Marvel Comics this also coincides with
the idea that in the modern day Captain
America is the de facto leader of the
Avengers his word is almost universally
accepted as law you can have the
entirety of the Avengers you can have
100 members of the Avengers in a room
arguing over what stuff they should take
next and some campaign that's going on
somewhere Captain America will stand up
he will speak everybody will stop they
will listen and when he says this is
what we're doing that's what will get
done and so it's really a cool thing to
see his character depicted in this
manner and so they basically have you
know frankly Frank Simpson saying look
I'm trying to respect our boys I'm
trying to respect our guys in the
military I'm trying to win the war that
they lost I'm trying to make America
great again you know someone long those
lines what it basically does is it leads
to the idea the Frank symptom is
essentially beyond hope beyond
redemption and is effectively insane and
that's the nature of his character he's
just a crazy guy and so because of this
we end up having him subdued by Captain
America and by Sam Wilson and then taken
by shield and placed in custody but what
we end up finding out here is that this
is all been a part of the plan
iron nail and the reason why is because
of the fact that Shen has been giving or
he's the one that was giving nuke all
the information that he needed he was
the one that was sending nuke on all
these different campaigns and the one
having him interact with all this stuff
knowing that shield wasn't really going
to arrest him and was going to take him
into custody the reason why he did that
is because an explosive had been planted
inside of nuke and living up to his
namesake chin detonates the explosive
effectively sending shield into a state
of disarray after which he initiates his
second phase which is to basically free
doctor mind level the guy who was
responsible for launching the weapons -
program and the guy that has the ability
to effectively ensnare people in little
pockets of reality if he so wishes by
trapping them inside one of his bubbles
it's really crazy the events that are
getting ready to go down are absolutely
insane but again all this is going to
lead into Steve Rogers losing his super
soldiers here all this is going to lead
into him becoming an old man setting the
stage for Sam Wilson to become the new
Captain America but with that being said
guys we're going to bring this video to
an end if you are new here to come as
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rock or if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]